Thank you.
All right, it being the appointed hour of 9 o'clock, we'll go ahead and open the Jalcar meeting.
I apologize for being the last minute.
It was 12 degrees and I was in my outdoor hot tub and I didn't want to get out.
All right, we'll start with the Pledge of Allegiance.
Senator Reardon, would you mind leading us?
Pledge of Allegiance to the flag of the United States of America and to the republic for which it stands, one nation under God, indivisible, with liberty and justice for all.
MR.
And the first order of business will be adoption of the minutes from last month.
Do I have a motion to approve the minutes it's been moved by uh representative lay on second and by senator ward is there any discussion about the minutes seeing done all those in favor say aye aye all those opposed nay the ayes have it and minutes are adopted next up is the uh consent to calendar uh to entertain a motion Yes.
Can we just appear next to all?
Or do we do a point to the author?
Sure.
Who do we have that needs to be appointed?
I'm guessing who do we have?
We have, I'm here.
Tara's here.
What's that?
Yep.
So we'll go ahead point.
So, we have the point we have anybody here from the Senate.
Yep.
I'm just looking at the Senate side on the house side.
We've got Erica, Jackie, Carol.
Schmitt.
We'll go ahead and seat Representative Potenza for Senate Innes.
Okay, that's 10.
Is that all set?
You okay over there?
Okay.
Peter, you good now?
I'm fine with whatever you want to do.
Thanks sir.
Okay.
Peter, you good now?
I'm fine with whatever you want to do.
Thanks, sir.
Okay.
Next up is a consent to calendar and see a motion to approve the consent calendar.
So moved.
Okay.
It's been moved by Representative Lynn, seconded by Representative Schmidt to approve the content calendar as adopted.
Is any other discussion on a consent calendar?
Seeing none, all those in favor, say aye.
Aye.
All those opposed nay.
The ayes have it.
So a couple items on the regular calendar.
We have two items that are pending.
One is a manufactured housing installer standards from a preliminary objection we did.
We have not received yet the response, but they don't have they have until next month to be able to respond.
So I anticipate the next 30 days we'll get that.
The next item is the dental, the dental examiners board and through agreement, the chair and I, as well as the director agreed to waive the deadline, give them more time till April.
They are working on a resolution with the people that were the stakeholders.
So we agreed to waive their deadlines and let them come back at the April meeting to address the whole sedation issue.
I almost said euthanasia.
And I think that was a different thing.
So the sedation issue.
I almost said euthanasia.
I think that was a different thing.
So the sedation issue.
Is there any other business?
With that, we have nothing else on the other business.
Is there anything else to discuss?
Representative Leon.
Yes.
I believe that we're going to have some informational session and some training.
So I don't know if that would fall under other business.
Yep.
I just want to make sure we'll step into the training as soon as we're done.
I just want to make sure representatives and senators don't have anything they want to comment on before we go into the training.
Again, the training is going to be talking about, you know, how Jalcar works, you know, what kind of motions we're allowed to make and what we can't make or why we can make the motions, that kind of thing, and what the process looks like.
So if there's no other business i'm going to turn it over to doug and his staff so they can take up the training we need to cancel the continued menu meeting if we want to do that and then we can just adjourn and we can get into the training so obviously we don't need our contingent meeting so i'd obtain a motion to cancel a contingent meeting for this month i'll move move by representative is second by represent representative growth uh all those in favor say aye aye all those opposed nay eyes have it the meeting is canceled that for the contingent meeting and with that we've conducted all of our business and we are adjourned we're going to now have the training with the staff anybody wants to stick around and listen doug how long we expect no more than an hour so considering it was probably one of the the fastest job card meetings we've ever had in about 4 minutes.
Um, should be sticking around for an hour should be within your realm.
So everyone is aware that was actually the 1st time in the history of jail car that every item has been on consent.
Not continuing 1 other time when everything got postponed.
spawned.
Thank you.